[Music]
now tonight americans continue to suffer
under the surging costs of the biden
agenda of course the radical climate
alarmist religious cult agenda new green
dealism inflation continues to hover at
a 40-year high prices in the grocery
aisle continue to soar and gas prices
yep hit another new record high one
after another after another under joe
biden of course he artificially reduced
the world supply and gave up energy
independence now one example for example
all across california we're now seeing
the price of a gallon of gasoline
higher than the federal minimum wage
which is
7.25 an hour but of course as the crisis
build up and biden's approval rating
goes down to 32 percent the white house
they just try to blame putin they blame
covert they blame fox they blame hannity
they blame trump and today they blame
the federal reserve and meanwhile
biden's energy crisis is going from bad
to worse as the international energy
agency is warning
fuel shortages this summer could be
worse than the oil crisis of the 70s for
those of you that don't remember those
days i grew up waiting online odd days
even days for maybe ten dollars worth of
gas maybe five at the time now it all
comes as americans are growing more and
more pessimistic about the biden economy
look at the gallup numbers the economic
confidence index has now cratered to a
whopping minus 45 that's the lowest
since the tail end of the recession in
2009 here with reaction fox business
host larry kudlow and that recession was
pretty steep and deep and wide i really
have two questions i don't see that
they're doing a single thing to me
that would help us recover
as a matter of fact
one of the best things they could do for
inflation is return to energy
independence that would be an easy fix
for inflation and the high cost of
everything we buy in every store we go
to number one number two
you know the economy as well as anybody
i know
for those americans two-thirds of which
are now living paycheck to paycheck what
advice do you give them what about their
401ks what about their iras their
retirement money what do you tell them
to do at this point
well sean i thank you for having me on
again and let me tackle the first point
you know biden's article in the wall
street journal today that was the talk
of the town had no new
inflation plan anti-inflation plan it
had nothing i mean what he's setting us
up here is for his vision this woke
vision of a fossil free economy which is
going to do enormous damage to the
economy it'll put it in a permanent
recession it'll cause millions of job
losses and rising unemployment and of
course as you can see the gas prices and
the diesel prices and the world oil
price i mean that's gone back to 120
dollars so inflation is going to rage he
had no plan today he wants fossil free
he knows it's going to cause a recession
and i don't think they care and i think
all this talk in this wall street
journal article about a transition i
think he's saying it's a transition
to fossil free and it's a transition to
recession and they're trying to
sugarcoat it and people are going to see
right through it so it's a terrible ploy
i mean look you want to end inflation i
got a plan okay this will call it the
kudlow hannity plan because you know i
think you're moving up the ladder to a b
or a b-plus in economics thanks a lot i
got a bad bad last week
[Laughter]
i'm now i'm picking it up here i'm
absolutely picking it up look a domestic
spending freeze
cut tax rates for supply-side economic
growth
open up the spigots for drilling of oil
and gas and pipelines
deregulate business d
yeah you can frack deregulate all of
business stop these price controls and
then protect king dollar the fed is
going to have to raise interest rates
and take some cash out of the economy
now that would be an anti-inflation plan
but that's not what you saw in the paper
today what you saw in the paper today is
no oil and gas production increases more
build back better for five trillion
dollars tax wealthy people successful
earners and corporations and regulate
business left and right so it's the
exact opposite okay and that is the
problem and that's why this inflation is
not going away
all right so we'll beg opec and they'll
reject us again they'll do a bad deal
with iran that's really dumb making the
muellers rich again uh do business with
the murdering dictator thug in venezuela
but let me go to the part b of my
question which was for all for every
american that has you know money in the
stock market a 401k
an ira whatever it happens to be what do
you say to them as they see their
hard-earned retirement money
dwindling by the hour
well look at
i believe in stocks for the long run
uh this woke big government socialism
from joe biden that's damaging the real
value of stocks is going to go away it's
not going to last the cavalry's coming
the congress is going to change in 2022
this november and so will the white
house in 24. look at sean do my advice
is folks don't sell i actually think the
stock market has more downside okay we
have not seen the bottom but i would
still say don't sell
buy as the market goes down stocks for
the long run is the best way to do it
and finally if you have some cash buy
the treasury savings bonds they're
called i bonds they're indexed for
inflation the yield is about 10 percent
so try a savings bond and stay in the
market do not out time the market stocks
in the long run the cavalry's coming
these crazy woke policies are not going
to last the test of time larry the
cavalry will start in 2023 assuming
republicans take over the house and
senate but you need the house the senate
and the white house to really get the
job done so this is going to be yeah
this is going to be a lot longer than
people wish i know for sure all right
larry kudlow thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else